this arm will only go so far so it's no
good you you got to get you've got to
shape round it when you get here you
need your feet to be this one in the
middle of Dan's two and that one
pointing that way if it's anywhere
different it's not Keyhole I'm going to
na it's only a little stretch but and
even though it won't move I want to
stret try and stretch to that corner
with the Top Hand as I
lower
P
herey protect yourself against the whole
body protect yourself against the whole
body look
up the go they don't want to go over so
I'm telling you about all the pain that
so if you don't want to go over you tell
them just to load you up
you C and do it look it's a
combination it's combination it's not
here down you protect you look up you
stretch out and you just load up you
know that you throw if it feels that
it's not there don't throw don't just
think well I got F I want to I'm try to
teach you
to be sensible people
if the throw is
there it will be there it'll feel light
won't feel heavy